I'm gonna have to turn this video around
real quick because the situation of
Warner Brothers is changing daily
welcome to council geeks my name is
Nathaniel Wayne I'm joined tonight by
Ryan Daley and we're covered I guess
ramble about what's going on at Warner
Brothers in regards to DC movies I I
don't know what else there is to say cuz
like literally every day it seems like
something else comes out about what is
or isn't going on um if you want to just
sort of leave with your general feeling
because I did a very ranting video all
already so badge of honor first video
I've ever had where someone told me to
kill myself so hey the point of your
video is basically that they should just
stop yeah quit at this point I don't
think they can right the ship I think
they need to blow up the ship and build
a new one I completely I think I was
there maybe after Man of Steel stronger
feelings about that movie than you did
or very many more negative feelings yeah
I mean I just and I said as much after
Batman vs Superman even if they do
another Superman solo movie or a solo
Batman movie with Ben Affleck cool I was
not the problem with Batman vs Superman
I don't want to spend time with this
Batman anymore I didn't I wasn't looking
forward to seeing another two-hour
two-and-a-half-hour movie with this
particular version of Batman for the
longest time it seems just inevitable
that it was going to be directed by Ben
Affleck who was having story control he
was code drafting the story with Geoff
Johns I have to wonder if he felt
bullied into the director's chair either
by Warner Brothers or by the fans who
wouldn't let it go because honestly he
spent the better part of a year year and
a half not confirming that he was
directing that he seemed to really be
going out of his way to not commit to
the fact that he was directing that
thing and then he finally did and then
only months later will you bear that
position
before he was even cast as Batman it was
rumored for like a week that he was in
talks to direct Batman vs Superman or
they officially gave it to Zack Snyder
and he was like no no was gonna happen
and then a week later okay so the
meetings were about him being cast at
Batman
so yeah I mean I do think there was
there was a folks where the fans wanted
it to happen maybe he did feel pressured
into it and he sort of famously it's
become a meme now where he said I will
only direct it if the script is good and
now he's out a few weeks ago he said I'm
not going to direct it so they're like
well yeah if y plus B equals yeah we now
know for certain he's not directing it
yeah what is up for debate because there
keep being people like it well I have a
source that says and then official
people are like no that's not the case
so what is up for debate is whether or
not they are keeping his script because
there are some sources that are saying
there's a page-one rewrite it works
there are others that say no we're
keeping the script that he and Jeff John
worked on and I I have heard like from
some sources and again who knows if any
of this is true Louis or says the
original script was very much sort of
took a lot of cues from the hush
storyline by Jeph Loeb and Jim Lee it's
a it's a legacy story it's a story that
requires a lot of information built up
which Warner Brothers seems to have not
understood because so was the Dark
Knight Returns which was their whole
inspiration for Batman vs Superman but
so yeah so they might be rewriting the
script from page 1 after Affleck want it
they they came out really quickly and
said okay the next director in line is
Matt Reeves who is working on the next
plane out of the Apes movie and he blank
okay I felt so bad I was listening to a
podcast today and I'm a little bit
behind on my Vespa it's only like a week
it's not even a week old but they're
like so it's probably gonna be Matt
Reeves directing the rabbit that's a
good get and I'm listening like going
he's already bailed on talks right and
and the way they like The Hollywood
Reporter broke the story and their
phrasing of it just like in the words
and maybe this is just the language that
they used but they said they might come
back together they might renegotiate
when their heads went with cooler heads
that suggests there was some sort of
contention or anger or like that they
they got really heated in their
negotiations I think did he walk away
because they were pissed at each other
it's like what the heck is going on in
this discussion gets up if I were to
make a guess and then this is complete
mm-hmm you know guess work in some
position I had no sources of anything
right but I would say if things got
heated over anything it would be what to
what degree he would have control over
the final cut of the movie because I
have a pretty strong feeling that at
this point mm-hmm Warner because if you
look at who because they have signed
someone to direct Shazam and I forget
the guys name I'm Samberg something
Edgar who is this Ari I I haven't seen
any of his work so I can't say whether
he's any good or not but he's directed
stuff like lights out and Annabelle too
I mean this is it he he's not into
someone who you could pin as an
up-and-comer the way that the director
of Doctor Strange was his early cuz he
oh he had insidious which was a really
big deal but so it feels like they're
jettison jettison their old approach of
let's get our tour directors and let
them do the row thing which is what they
did
it worked for them when they got
Christopher Nolan yeah it worked for
them when they had Tim Burton no it
didn't work when it was Joel Schumacher
mm-hm
it didn't work with Zack Snyder but it
seems like they are backing away from
this let's get really visionary
directors and just let them do their
thing and Matt Reeves visionary might be
strong term but he's a guy with a very
bold approach and and I I don't know for
certain if you have final cut but he had
pretty he did not deal with a lot of
interference with his work on the to
AIDS movies he's done John plenty for
the upcoming war Planeteers so if he
went in thinking or expecting that he
was going to get the same degree of
leeway that say Snyder did when he did
BBS and they're like no absolutely not I
can see tempers getting heated over that
I'm saying you know I don't need this
guy yeah he's and he doesn't so couple
that with like they're like okay well if
he's not going to do it who is I heard
them say two names one I didn't
recognize there was another guy who's
got a few minor credits
and the other Ridley Scott well I guess
congratulations to the guy I've never
heard of because it's not gonna be
written no it's not gonna be Ridley
Scott I have the earth would he come to
work a Batman movie a deal with all of
that he's also trash-talked the
superhero movie genre well so has Mel
Gibson who is apparently hidden sparks
that our Suicide Squad - which makes no
has Mel Gibson ever Donald work-for-hire
directing gig I don't think he ever has
if he was in the position of desperation
like where he needed a comeback or
something well he does hacks our range
did decently at the box yeah that thing
it got good notices that's why I feel
like he doesn't need this no I'm not
sure I'm not sure who does but although
I have to say I guess that was actually
that was also the first time I had ever
heard any word about a sequel so that's
what I was gonna say I was surprised to
hear that as soon as I see what sequel
is even in the works because my thought
was that the Gotham City sirens moved
that they were doing was going to
basically sub in instead of a suicides
write a sequel is that word they
basically go look let's take the one
element that pretty much most people
said was decent or or could have worked
give that its own thing rather than try
and sequel eyes this right that that had
been my assumption but for numbers with
their film slate of these DC properties
they would have three counting three
movies that are centered around the
villains or they sort of evil characters
either completed or in production yeah
because they recently said something
that makes a lot of commercial sense it
makes no creative sense you're talking
about the black out of black atom thing
they basically they've had cast for
years the rock Dwayne the rock Johnson
as the character Black Adam who is the
villain of Shazam they don't have a new
script well then I do think you haven't
had a script versus an for a while now
but they hadn't had a director for years
they now gotten one like a week ago yeah
they haven't cast anybody and they've
got their villain who was sure Dwayne is
getting older and getting less and less
patient he doesn't need this either
which allows like if this doesn't
I don't think it's gonna come as a very
big surprise yeah but they basically
said why are we taking a matter of his
caliber and his bank ability and making
him the secondary focus like the villain
of this movie
let's give him his own movie as the
character as a prequel to the heroes
movie because it's all about his fall
from grace and then Shazam is sort of
the redemption story that's from from
studio executive logic that makes sense
from air from any narrative perspective
that makes no sense because even if you
try and go antihero with him if he if he
is in fact here of that first movie
you're either gonna end up with a very
compromised first movie cuz he has to
end up bad by the end of it or you're
gonna kneecap your second movie where
the guy who you rooted for in the last
one suddenly you've got some new guy who
you've never seen before taking him on
and you're expected to be on their side
now what some people have hope for a
Wonder Woman I don't I don't know where
you are on that I haven't seen or heard
anything specifically or overtly that
leads me to think they're going to get
it wrong I just have zero confidence and
their ability to get it right based on
the track record so far if it bombs and
it's just going to speed you're going to
expedite the process of kill this then
you put it this thing out of its misery
and that's the reason so and that's and
that's why I'm Rudy against because I
love wonderful right but I figured
there's no way Wonder Woman can be great
and they tie and and if it's not gonna
be great I would rather it just tank and
speed this process along and the reason
I figure it can't be great is because
regardless of anything else they were
pretty much done filming by the time BBS
it's it's a spinoff of that one it was
that was envisioned it was conceived
filmed and now they may be trying to fix
it in editing Lord knows that certainly
worked for Suicide Squad but it was
conceived when they thought the Snyder
vision was what they wanted for the in
what the fans wanted for the universe
the two that were scheduled to come out
next year are he said Aquaman which
seems to be chugging along
to be fine it hasn't been any
controversy about that one and I have to
wonder if that's gonna be this this
thing's last shot it might now the one
that was supposed to come before that
was the flash there's no way that's half
okay let's go through the history of
this homeboy so originally way back when
originally Lord and Miller the Lego
bending or not legal baton but the lego
movie guys get brought in to be the
runners of this to bring the story
together possibly to direct and
everything like that they would you busy
to direct but they were of the script
they brought in Seth grahame-smith
something the long those lines was it
was an odd twist cuz he hasn't directed
you note no yes directed then he isn't
right right he wrote the script with the
agreement that he could direct it as
well and then he was taken off
yeah and they brought in a new director
his name escapes me for the moment but
to work with that script a few months
ago that director leaves citing creative
differences with the studio and that
they couldn't get along they couldn't
agree on a shared vision so give up so
they've now lost at least two directors
if you don't count warden Miller
yeah who are never officially signed but
I think there had been a hope that they
would write and most recently we heard
that they've hired somebody else to do a
page one rewrite of the script from a
flash yeah so Seth grahame-smith or
whatever his his script so whoever like
this is like the third writer on the
project and eventually we might get a
third director on the project if it
happens I don't think like there they
would have to make a movie with the
production value all flash movie and
female all the visuals that it's not
gonna come out in 2018 I think the only
reason they haven't moved the release
date is because they want to be able to
put it somewhere else
they don't want to just say it's not
this table we don't know when it is I
think they want to go
no it's move to X date but they don't
know when when they can move it to yet I
think that's the only reason they
haven't officially cancelled that that
March 2018 when they stood and and I
think I think at that point if because
if Warner Brothers and Justice League
I'm not gonna say tank cuz I think I
much like from any actual numbers
perspective be biessed in tanks Suicide
Squad didn't I know that but
they well BBS definitely under
performance I don't know what the
expectation was on Suicide Squad - as
far as it being embraced by critics and
the fans it definitely failed on that
measure
I think after Deadpool and the hype from
the original trailers and teasers
versus that's why the host - that might
have inflated their hopes right before
the release BBS definitely
underperformed because it didn't even
make a billion and that should have been
a billion and a half yeah movie easy
yeah that should have been a slam dunk
so if Wonder Woman and Justice League
both underperform oh man I figure we'll
still happen because it'll be too far
along
mm-hmm but at that point I think if
those two underperform
that would be the last one because even
if that one is a home run they're still
gonna dismantle this this universe by
that point they'll have made the
decision ultimately I would be okay with
that like I said like I'm not I'm not
championing these movies because they're
giving me versions of these characters
that I don't want to spend time with and
I also don't need to see them because
I've got other avenues to see these
characters or other comic-book movies
that I can rely on let's get creative
okay okay we've done our sort of okay we
think this thing should be put out of
its misery
yeah what should they do that what
should Warner Brothers do okay there's a
part of me that wants the flash movie to
morph into a flat nut literally do
flashpoint but use flash as a means to
reboot the universe full and you know
that we did do it begin and I actually I
kind of smile at that idea now now again
I want to emphasize I'm not saying
actually adapt the flashpoint story
because that's even darker than what
they are already doing we don't need
that but you have to basically create a
new film you guys you use that concept
of the flash go running so fast he
creates a temporal boom then it throws
everything else and we get a new
universe that way I and I think what
that wouldn't enable them to do if they
actually did it would be to reboot this
thing much faster because if they don't
reboot it in universe the question
becomes how long do we how
we have to wait that people will be
willing to let us try again and I don't
know the answer to that I mean my
default thought is minimum three years
using flash to reboot the the universe
in continuity would enable them to keep
cranking out at a two-year pace that's
true
and the reason why I'll never be in
charge of the studio is because I
wouldn't do that I would have a wait and
give it time to to settle and be
forgotten and that's why I don't make
those decisions what I would do is I
would actually split and go take the the
Werner the DC entertainment properties
that they own and go into wildly
different directions I would focus on
more adult-oriented vertigo style things
I okay like before getting to Guillermo
del Toro's Justice League dark or dark
universe thing before you bring in all
those characters do those one at a time
take another shot at a Swamp Thing movie
oh yeah you could do a legit Swamp Thing
movie with a John Constantine cameo who
wouldn't love that oh yeah and then you
could and you could then see Constantine
for his own movie right um you could do
a Spectre type of thing like that you
could you know bring in some of those
characters a demon all those things but
do those slowly build up the vertigo
like they were still you haven't heard
about this for years but Joseph
gordon-levitt was working on the same
man for he's off that he's been off that
way I mean there's been talking to
Sandman movie four as so try something
like that going in the other direction
more kids move kid friendly even
animation projects besides just the Lego
movies I still think Captain Marvel not
the Marvel one but Shazam yeah I think
that would be a great kids movie a great
animated movie because at its heart it's
a little kid's wish fulfillment to
become Superman
but you can distinguish it from Superman
who would be your main live-action hero
by making it a little bit different by
making the focus and the emotional core
of the movie which it should be is I'm
Billy it's this kid who is orphan who is
left alone who needs help and at the
world blow at the point where he's
lowest he says the magic word and he
gets these powers and you get the
learning curve that could be a great it
could be it could be just classical
animation it could be Pixar style or 3d
or
something like that but I mean I think
if you take the tone of big hero 6 hmm
and and that type of tone and put it on
a Shazam type of character
I think wonderful that would that would
also require some serious restructuring
if they were good because it would it
would basically mean the death of DC of
DC animation as it currently exists
which normally I would be puli against
but at this point has you've seen enough
bad ones on the road yes yeah there have
been a couple of good ones even amongst
the bad ones but at this point going by
the last three or four years the bad
ones outnumber the good ones at this
point when they're bad they're really
bad so much of the the ones that they've
been doing though at least the last
couple ones that I've seen are just
straight adaptations and I don't feel
like they're having enough creative like
regional use that have been good we're
the ones that were the most original
gods and monsters might turn on the
Caped Crusader's even assault on Arkham
yeah took a lot of cues from things but
was not directly adapting anything right
and it's you know all their ones based
off the new 52 are absolute slugs
yeah except for bad blood but that one
was just nuts thinking about the Batman
if they were doing a page one rewrite of
a Batman movie stop playing to this idea
of we have one vision of Batman and
embrace the fact that Batman belongs to
everybody and everybody has their
preferred Batman I would make an analogy
movie with Batman I would make it sort
of like a four rooms or type of thing
where you've got three different
45-minute Batman stories because at his
heart he is a detective character and
you think about like movie mystery TV
shows they're all about an hour without
commercials 45 minutes perfect time for
a little mystery and you could have one
be a little bit silly a little bit more
than the campy vein where he's going up
against the Mad Hatter for some reason
the map The Riddler actually writes
exactly something like that you could
have one that is much more dark much
more like urban even a little bit scary
you know something like that you could
have
one that is more traditional superhero
you could have one that feels a little
bit gritty err I mean you don't want
them to be so drastically different from
each other that it's a jolly for the
audience because you want to have some
tether or some gap but just something
like that like the way Sin City was when
an adapted three different stories were
ever put them in this movie or something
like that where you got the one tether
is you've got Batman and Alfred same
actors and all of them but maybe three
different directors three different
scripts basically doing mini movies but
you cut them all together and you
arrange them in a way that you've got a
two hour 20 minute whenever production
they they have such a staple but they
can't look past the members of the
Justice League basically and I I almost
wonder if part of that isn't the fact
that people have been shouting for so
long why are you making a Justice League
movie why aren't you looking at we have
to be there's a certain amount of
culpability on the fans for this because
we have they are they're failing at it
but they are in a certain way trying to
give the movies that we said we want
advance for a long time said they wanted
something inspired by the Dark Knight
Returns fans for a long time said they
wanted to see what happens when Batman
and Superman fight I mean that let's be
fair they didn't they in terms certainly
in terms of BBS Warner Brothers did not
force this material down our throats Oh
a very high percentage of the fan base
has been asking for this that's true
Oz if they just made a Batman movie
after Warner Brothers I still might not
have loved it but the mentality that
Zack Snyder brought would have worked
much better in a movie that only had
Batman in it sure it was clear that that
was the character that he liked and the
character like yeah like it would he
have done better if he if he just
approached to the solo Batman movie yes
probably go home Warner Brothers you're
drunk yes I would like them to restart
it because I like the characters but
well here's the thing I would be very
skeptical about it being restarted until
some people at Warner Brothers top brass
get fired I've always heard that's a
thing about Warner Brothers as a company
as a corporate entity that they
micromanage all of their little things
like they've done yeah they've got their
fingers and lots of different pies and
those fingers keep messing up the pies
yeah I mean to compare and to compare it
to say Disney they have someone who
heads Pixar and they let that person
head Pixar they have John Lasseter
heading Disney Animation they let him do
that they have Kevin Feige heading
Marvel movies they let him do back that
Kathleen kind of a running Lucasfilm
yeah and they they let the people that
they've given that job to actually do
that job and only when things go south
will those people be removed from that
job they're not being overridden by
somebody above them yes until until
there's a management shakeup at Warner
Brothers I even a reboot I'll be
skeptical here's the thing that I was
saying what Marvel doesn't the amount of
control that they have over things
comparing the two Marvel could never
make a movie as good as the Dark Knight
I don't think they would ever allow
someone with that degree of vision to
have the degree of control that they
would need to make a movie that good
mm-hmm but I also don't believe that
Marvel could make a movie as bad as
Suicide Squad or Batman V Superman it is
the chain restaurant mmm and I mean
hyerin i mean like Olive Garden I'm
sorry young it's not McDonald's but it's
like Olive Garden you have it you have a
certain base level you know it won't be
bad it's not gonna blow my mind the way
going down to some obscure little
restaurant I've never heard of well but
you're also not going to get food
poisoning weeds that obscure restaurant
you've never heard of might well poison
you know that yeah no that's completely
fair and I've said as much like there
does seem to be more of a house style a
familiarity a comfort zone in the Marvel
movies they don't they might say they're
taking risks by doing something new but
they're not really taking that much risk
no ads dr. strange wasn't that different
no no it was and I remember um guardians
of the galaxy being called the riskiest
sure thing and they're like that kind of
sums it up like it's a risk within
within acceptable parameters but at this
at this point I will take reliably
entertaining movies over
having my
brain kicked in with a boot with dog
crap on it what might what film can that
not be said about well thanks so much
for uh for sabe and Ryan you do too much
what do you feel like plugin I'll make
this short and sweet I've got a number
of podcasts on the fire and water
podcast network go to Fire Water podcast
comm and you can check out some of my
shows there alright that works so thanks
for much for joining us thank you for
watching if you are watching this on
youtube you can check out a more-or-less
unedited longer version of this
conversation on the podcast the council
of geeks podcast available on iTunes and
stitcher thank you for for watching and
or listening and until next time this
council is a jerk